For a decade Washington, DC, has been a
celebrated national model of school
reform. Then, in January, and audit showed that one third of DC's high school
graduates should not have received
diplomas. Indeed, it turns out that the
system's true graduation rate is lower
than it was in 2011. How could this have
gone unnoticed? Blogger Alexander
Rousseau has placed part of the blame on
rank boosterism by the capital's
preeminent news outlet. But this coverage
reflects a larger problem: the bandwagon
mentality in school reform. Since 2007,
philanthropists have poured more than a
hundred and twenty million dollars into
DC schools, and advocates and think tanks were lauded for glowing accounts of
developments in DC. It was easy for
reformers to feel they'd be labeled
unhelpful or anti reform for going
off-script. This all fueled a "with us or
against us" mindset in which no one
looked too hard for problems.
DC should be a wake-up call for a
school reform culture that has been
heavy on cheerleading and light on
skepticism.
What do you make of the Washington, DC, graduation rate scandal? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.